hello and welcome to gamespot's coverage
of e3 2016. we are live from the los
angeles convention center here in la
california for the next two days showing
off no fewer than six press conferences
the first of which ea is kicking off in
about 30 minutes time and we won't be
done after that e3 then opens on tuesday
and on this very stage we'll be playing
host to a bunch of game developers
coming on sharing their games on tuesday
wednesday and thursday so make sure you
stick with us for the whole week uh
obviously in light of the horrifically
tragic events that unfolded in orlando
video games can seem like a pretty
trivial thing so before we kick off the
show i just want to say to everyone
who's watching regardless of your gender
race sexual preference we hope you're
doing all right and we're delighted to
have you with us today i'm also
delighted to be joined by a couch full
of my international friends and
colleagues scott butterworth
representing the san francisco office
lucy james from the uk jolly o london
london calling uh and jess from wherever
whoever like roadhog
yeah you're from that
overwatch it's like roadhog and and
junkrat are from
yeah that's the place that i come from
yeah it's great it's in the australian
mad max yeah us two great yeah babies
yes specifically she was in the original
mad max she has an age today yeah nice
work your hair's growing country yeah
yeah yeah
there's only five people that live there
yeah and russell crowe already left
yeah him and tucker uh we've got a bunch
of stuff to talk about over the next 25
minutes uh ea are going well we do but a
lot of it's been leaked for us dude this
morning it's crazy like everything's out
there already well not everything but uh
yeah like substantial number of leaks
which i'm sure we'll touch on right now
yeah so i guess the first things first
uh the i guess ea were doing their dress
rehearsal and someone hit the go switch
left the car i mean i feel like this
happens like we do a live show every
single year right full of like all of
these you know
professionals and talented individuals
who know what the hell they're doing so
do all of these other companies but
every year somebody manages to slip one
out was it dishonored too last year yeah
yeah was so what happened with ea this
year who who's actually seen it yeah
jess you saw it all right so what did
you do what happened was
very unluckily
when it was hit
uh someone accidentally said it live
they were taking a look at titanfall's
single player okay
wonderful
which is really interesting because
obviously one of the main criticisms of
titanfall was that you know they they
were very multiplayer focused and they
had said in the past that they wanted to
stay multiplayer focused because they
wanted to release on time they didn't
want the extra pressures of like you
know single player yeah small enough
team to impede on everything they were
trying to accomplish with multiplayer
but i think what happened was a lot of
people found you know the the titan
pilot dynamic and the world they were
building quite intriguing and felt like
it could be super great for a single
player campaign and fortunately it
sounds like ea and reese one are
listening yeah and uh so yeah we got
kind of a you know your classic gritty
single-player shooter trailer going and
uh it looks like they're going to
explore the relationship between titans
and pilots and
and also titans seem to be quite a bit
more complicated right it's weird titans
are sentient yeah
so the problem ai
yeah like there's now interactions
between those piloting the mech suits
and the mech suit itself yeah kind of
big daddy-esque though they have the uh
the relationship with that pilot that's
that's the their core programming is
together it feels very robotic inside of
themselves yes
an extremely literal way yes yes it's so
it's strange because a lot of this stuff
has like appeared and then there's been
screenshots and news articles and then
there's been dmca notices which have
pulled them down so like some of it has
been very readily available and then
they're completely unavailable so i
guess the things that were in that
trailer were like one it looked a lot
more colorful that's what was
interesting and two there was you know
there was one of the maps in titanfall
where it was all these flying things
that were like killing you every once in
a while they were like kind of flying
overhead
and people were like oh i wonder what
like other animals are in this you know
on this world and the trailer had a
bunch of like weird little creatures and
stuff yeah all sorts of things i mean
there's so much new stuff we were
talking about earlier and it's just it's
bright and colorful and they have all
these environments and stuff and like
there are fleshing out characters i'm
really interested to see what they're
going to do with it have you guys seen
the big titan that's somewhere here oh
he's in l.a live we saw him getting
built all right
live beside the the doritos
ass arcade machine thing did you see
that i haven't seen that no it's in the
um the main square just next to the
nokia theater i think wonderful stuff
it's absurd it's so big yeah yeah i mean
it's either that or the world of
warplanes thing which which didn't show
up this year so
i guess we've we've got uh vinson pelota
thanks for that let's let's wander on
from that another thing that actually
apparently appeared during that live
stream was some sort of star wars game
now we know that there is the amy hennig
thing happening we know that uh is it
the folks who made dead space uh what
are they called visceral games also
working on as one as well um i'm
guessing we're going to see something to
do with either of those games lucy i'd
hope so i mean
they've got they've obviously got some
kind of deal worked out with lucas so
they can have a bunch of star wars games
have to come out if we're not seeing any
more of battlefront i imagine we'll see
something right because there's motive
working on one as well right oh yeah
yeah so they have a bunch of projects in
the pipeline and even if they did what
they did a couple of years ago where
they just sort of revealed like concept
art and you know developers working in
darkened rooms like what they did with
andromeda pretty much saying this game
is coming we'll tell you more already
i'd be happy with that yeah we're going
to see a lot of that i mean yeah you
have always got so many games to talk
about every year because on top of this
they have so many other annualized
franchises with all the sports stuff as
well and so they students see what they
squeeze in uh but you brought it up mass
effect andromeda dropped it in all we
saw before was that little sliver thanks
to the good people at linkedin
yeah or youtube
uh yeah like uh some sort of artist put
up a bunch of like you put an animation
showroom yeah yeah yeah so we've seen a
little bit more although apparently that
was a couple years old yeah that it went
up so right it's speculated that i mean
those mechanics i mean they showed off
like a jet pack kind of traversal system
for characters so that may or may not
still be in the game it may or may not
still look like that but
i'm hoping for jet packs i think that'd
be kind of great yeah i mean
it feels like massive you know so often
we get sequels when they're it's a
little bit too soon yeah it's been a
while since mass effect oh yeah they've
pushed it to march 2017 now so that'll
be five years want it four five years i
think what's really cool is this will be
the first mass effect that's not part of
the commander shepard trilogy like we
might have to explore new portions of
this universe which is such a
well-established and rich universe i'm
really excited to see where they go with
the narrative and like what characters
we're interacting with i mean we know
we're in a very different part of the
galaxy i think like at least 100 years
after the conclusion of the previous
trilogy so
so many unanswered questions i really
hope ea shows more of that than we've
seen in the past
really battlestar galactica as well like
if because there was a huge reddit leak
a while ago and then a very similar one
for dragon age and the dragon h1 turned
out to be completely legit yeah but from
the sounds of andromeda it's also like
you're the pathfinder finding a new home
for humanity which is very much battle
star right yeah yeah they're running
from the cylons they've lost they just
need to find a new home so i'm really
hoping that kind of
vibe is there
i mean i love the mass effect games i
think they're incredible rpgs i'd love
to see it deliver a little more on
planet exploration yes and this seems
like a perfect opportunity you know they
have these
these great like dense
like races and lore associated with all
them and stuff like that and there's
history and because we've had three
games packed full of it we're aware of a
lot of it so they've set up a wonderful
universe that we can access it'll just
be really interesting to see i mean i'd
love to
do more of of what we've seen in
previous games like actually explore a
lot of different kinds of planets that's
like frontier aspect there's always
exciting thing right it's like god what
are you gonna find on this one
completely new stuff with just like
totally divergent populations and things
like that i mean i always liken it to
how knights of the old republic handled
it like they did such a good job in that
game of feeling like you were entering a
whole new like right it's a completely
new experience every new planet felt
like a new planet yeah
like you know by the end of mass effect
3 sort of conversely you then had a
situation where like you know the
krogans and you know that weird like guy
in the citadel who talks like that yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
right yeah
haven't you yeah yeah
so yeah that that'll be super
fascinating
i imagine there will be some races that
will definitely kind of be series
staples we've already seen that krogan
were in that early concept art and
they're kind of like the cockroaches i
guess they're so difficult to kill i'd
imagine there'd be krogan oh yeah i'm
holding out the thing is i want some of
the old races but i want new stuff yeah
well that's a weird one
all right from from wars in the future
to wars in the past the first ever war
that was a very good segway thank you
battlefield yeah battlefield one uh i'm
guessing we're gonna they've been doing
these little like mini feature ed
teasers over the past week yeah you know
bringing a grenade to a tank battle and
all this sort of stuff i'm guessing
we're gonna see a bunch of battlefield 1
right i do wonder if we're going to get
a multiplayer review i think about like
a few years ago when they did the
battlefield 4 reveal and they went oh
and we've got all these people playing
it now right did they go to the roof or
something or was it hardline
very grateful for our frosted glass
surroundings right now no sunburns in
here nice and chilly today yeah but yeah
battlefield one it'll be interesting
actually i mean anything that you know
is gonna be interesting if they show
single-player stuff that'll be great
people it's fascinating
i think um
just like everything they've talked
about so far it seems like they have a
lot to work with do really interesting
combat mechanics and different ways of
approaching it and emphasis on melee
things like that that just suited the
time so they're going to suit the game
what i'm really interested to see is if
we see a single player campaign that can
get as gritty as of course the great war
would be right yeah yeah because at the
end of the day this is the one of the
world's biggest shooting franchises
which is about having a blast yeah the
great wall was
much less
having a fun time i mean like even if
you go back to first-person shooters
like stuff like call of duty the sort of
the bombast we're now used to in like
the modern cod games is is also a step
away from what they were when you go
back and play cod 1 and cod 2 or like
medal of honor for instance these sort
of like plodding experiences uh so yeah
it'll be very interesting i mean it
sounds like dice have really fought
their corner to get this made like the
word coming out is that some of the
folks at ea were not sure the first
world war was what to go back to but i
guess futuristic first person tutors are
all the vogue now right so it's
interesting to see them
purposely making a stand and going back
i mean they have titanfall so like as a
company it makes sense right split the
difference a bit and it seems like this
is what they've been approaching for
quite a long time i mean because
hardline was the same thing as they
wanted to do something it was like a it
was a cops and robbers game it wasn't a
modern warfare game so they've clearly
decided that they don't want to compete
directly with what call of duty's trying
to do and what better way to do that
than by going back to the series roots
and going back to the first world war i
guess battlefield probably started i
think as a world war ii game actually
1942 was yeah yeah but yeah so i mean
they've gone classic instead of modern
um so
honestly probably a good decision on
their part and and so far we've seen the
reaction everyone that i've seen talking
about it online seems much more excited
about
battlefield
versus call of duty infinite warfare for
sure i mean it seems like whatever they
show uh the folks will be happy speaking
of which if you have any questions at
all make sure to put them in the game
spot chat i'm keeping an eye there and
also on twitch.tv for gamespot i've got
both of them up here especially
afterwards because we're going to do a
sort of breakdown post show afterwards
as well uh with hopefully some more
details that we might know um but moving
on in terms of the games let's talk
about sports electronic arts
fifa got itself a story mode that's also
a leak oh thanks
so this has also been pulled down i
watched the trailer it's pretty short
and sweet
it kind of looks like that living the
dream stuff from nba 2k16 yeah yeah is
mike jones attached to this too this is
not a spike okay spike jones joint but
lee mike joins joint sorry not i don't
know which one spikey i'm pretty sure
now we're just gonna be confused pretty
sure i don't know no i don't know
actually someone in the comments will
correct us in the comments if any of
these spikes are in the chat let us know
that's a spike joint uh it looks so it's
on frostbite as well which is great they
flash up frostbite at the time you're
like great brother reena brilliant the
destructible soccer bridge is what we
always wanted that's what i've always
wanted football sorry um don't forget
your roots yes
from ireland you're an american now
buddy
so what do we think about this any uh do
any of you guys play fifa
okay fair enough no
what i think but battlefield though
where's
i mean
fight night champion was like a really
good
uh sort of uh re-imagining i don't know
like sort of rest starting off point
again for the fight night series uh
which had a like a super super good
story mode in it now that studio is now
working on the ufc games and obviously
that's based around people who are like
famous and they don't tend to do that
sort of stuff but that was like a really
good game which had that sort of like
you know cliched rags to riches you know
you know
sort of like boxer story
and i guess
that kind of exists within the world of
football as well so the traitor that we
saw has a named character
a playing for like manchester united and
then playing for england and like making
his way through it'll be interesting to
see if they allow you to not just be
that character though because fifa has
always been about i mean i'm sure you
know football players in france don't
want to necessarily go through i don't
want to even play for manchester united
watch the premier league i want to play
for arsenal so it'll be interesting to
see if like you know all that stuff they
had in the game were the commentators
would say your name if you put it in
like old wires in it so they say my name
yeah and it'll be interesting to see if
you can also pick women's football as
well for this mode because that's
obviously been a big big push for them
over the past couple of years uh but
yeah i guess we'll have to wait and see
as a soccer football fan are you excited
about a story mode is something that you
want so finite champion every single
time i have like interviewed the ea
people the fifa people specifically at
e3 for the past couple of years i have
said have you ever thought about doing a
story mode because that's it's the same
company right different studio obviously
but you know
how did that work out and what i heard
is the champion maybe because of when it
was released didn't necessarily do that
well and obviously that story took quite
a lot of time it's the same thing we've
always heard with like titanfall for
instance multiplayer single player you
know 50 don't play it whatever so
yes i'm very excited for that obviously
it's all in execution uh but we'll have
to see but the other thing is is that
whenever they do anything new in a in an
ea sports game is they roll it into all
the other ones
so what if there's a salmon
and the same in in nhl as well yeah it's
possible do it are there any other ea
sports games uh there's no more nascar
awards
yeah was he ea
i swear he was on the conference last
year i wondered who the nba street games
you say his name three times into a
mirror he appears uh we're about ten
minutes from the conference going live
but we still have a bunch more stuff to
talk about uh let's talk we just talked
about more star wars let's just talk
about all the star wars games i mean the
chances are we're going to see loads
i would certainly hope so oh my god
making several of them so what about um
the old republic
they had an expansion last year
and we know bioware are working well by
we're working on andromeda a secret new
ip right and they do have the republic
going on in the background are they
gonna do a new
update well that would be i mean that
would be four then because we have
visceral
we have motive
we have respawn yeah which got announced
last month i think
uh and then i mean
yeah
forget about lego star wars the force
awakens which is i don't this is not in
the game but it's a star wars well this
is what's happened after infinity i mean
always part of that whole thing you can
see the strategy now they're just
they're you know they're out there
licensing games again and the star wars
hasn't been bigger
in recent memory than it is right now
yeah i mean there's rogue one coming out
later this year as well yeah december
yeah so a bunch of stuff so i imagine if
there was ever a conference over the
next six days that we're going to see a
lot of star wars stuff at yeah it's
gonna be uh yeah yeah certainly i hope
so i imagine playstation as well
actually because they always do um the
forces strong with playstation yeah and
they've got that vr experience that they
talked about at gdc so hopefully we'll
see something of that i mean they said
that like we're making a star wars vr
game for psvr you'll see it eventually
maybe eventually is e3
yeah let's talk about that actually
because another thing that we've heard
over the past couple of days is that
ubisoft are going to be showing off a
bunch of virtual reality stuff we also
now know that the neo isn't going to be
front and center for sony which means
that's probably a lot to do with their
messaging about playstation vr and not
wanting to sort of muddy the water about
that
so i mean an educated guess means that
electronic guards are also going to like
jump in and show off like here are our
you know dipping our toe into the sort
of that's the right phrase because yeah
if we are going to see anything it's
probably going to be a very like
about it you won't letter
so far everything we've seen for vr has
come from much much smaller teams and a
lot of it's really great but we haven't
seen like you know there's no call of
duty vr that i'm aware of right i mean
there's been no
so far no real big major franchises like
triple a quote unquote aaa franchises
that have come to vr so maybe e3 we're
gonna start to see a little of that i'm
not aware of anything besides the star
wars experience that playstation is
talking about but i mean yeah maybe at
ea's conference we'll see a little bit
from them i think ea is a good place for
it because i mean you know ea has given
us a lot of like sweet indie games to
like get excited about yeah you know
they kind of i mean god bless madden and
fifa because those kind of bankroll
other projects
the first mercedes didn't really sell
that well but yeah they made another one
anyway and i appreciate that ea
historically has kind of done that like
they will take a risk on a game that
maybe is not going to do that they also
got access to a bunch of ips that they
could probably absolutely so one of the
leaks that happened a little while ago
was the idea that there might be some
sort of virtual reality battlefront
which would be
right
you're oh come on it'd be great i get
really motion sick in vr right you just
hear that and you're like
dude i want a mirror's edge vr i think
that would be great but that would kill
you you would like put that on the
mirror it kills me you know that button
where you can turn around 180 in like a
fraction of a second did you imagine
that
a little much for me and i generally
look emotional
do you remember when someone put um
uh not dead island um
dead rising no no no uh the one that
tech landed after dead space oh don't
wait diagonally
in vr and that was awful because it's
it's when the camera takes control away
from you when you vault over something
right that's when people might say but
i'm to be honest like stuff with um
vive now like vive i'm fine with so
it seems like the the motion sickness
problem is going away so if battlefront
were to come to vr
and hopefully they've taken the time to
smooth it all out yeah and being in
those environments though yeah just
being able to walk away yeah i want like
a star wars like a cockpit vr game this
cockpit seem to work really well with vr
you're seated and you've got like the
control panels you can like look every
direction i mean it works for e valkyrie
x-wing versus tie fighter right i mean
that would that would be fantastic yeah
make it happen 100
i wonder if the other thing they do with
the sports games is like like even stuff
like connect like the voice commands all
that stuff always gets it gets like a
little bit of a you know piecemeal tip
of the hat in those sports games like
imagine maybe if you could play fifa and
sit in the crowd imagine if you could be
the ball you could literally be the
soccer no why you always got to take it
you're like the worst
way possible
it's all about experience right now we
got to try different things and see what
works yeah you know there's no there's
no wrong answers in brainstorming that's
their approach they'll take unless you
tell somebody to make a soccer game in
which you are the ball that's probably a
bad idea yeah they should hack it for pc
i mean i'd play that like if you're
sitting in the crowd because the thing
about the tv camera is that it's like
sort of like moving with you a little
bit
in the yeah you can bang on the
walls when they're all fighting each
other go sharks
oh yeah good point yeah that's on today
yeah a lot of sports on at the moment um
i'm missing the end of the canadian
grand prix right here uh okay so we've
talked a lot about a lot of the you know
stuff we kind of thought we were going
to see stuff that has leaked
it's often very very very likely yeah um
new ip i mean ea i've already said an
earnings call that they're going to be
saying there's going to be something
between now and next year so i mean it
seems like a stupid question to ask
people what the new ip will be
what would you guys think the new ip
would be i'm hoping for a reveal like uh
unravel last year yeah let's unravel it
that's that's
like turning it into
because they have their other realms
covered we're getting these massive
amazing shooters we're going to get mass
effect we've got they have scales down
yeah so yeah what are they missing this
we have first person shooter we got two
big games is the surprises which is like
the indie games like unravel that we get
where it's just completely out of left
field and grabs everyone and it's like
oh wow that is an incredible thing that
no one saw coming which honestly i think
is the best part of e3 yeah yarny was
the unexpected hero of e3 2015 right
game wasn't that great okay listen it
was okay
but it was different danny you're not
wrong but he was here getting behind
something that was you know really
trying to do something very narrative
focused and completely like i mean
yes i agree that game had problems but i
don't think i've seen anything quite
like it and i really enjoy publishers
who are willing to back depths who want
to do games like that i mean you're not
really trying like what you're saying
everyone loves to try it yeah that's
true try even with like the small sort
of stuff i mean i guess it's you know
that you're right they do have a lot of
the bases covered they got the third
part i mean it looks like their star
wars game is probably going to be big
bombastic third-person games they have
their first person base covered they
have the sort of the sports stuff locked
down they've got rpgs yeah i think i
think the next dragon age will be
maybe next year
but the other thing it might be because
remember that like simpson's untapped is
an ea game right right right
the new people will be something more
social maybe even something mobile i
mean i'm sort of loath to be like you
know what he's going to be mobile yeah
a pup cap just got it right zombies too
yeah yeah sorry uh guard warfare two
plans for the other but also um
the sims as a thing has been popping up
i think they're calling it sims worlds
right it could be the new pro uh the the
new game from mike that's like which
should kind of be considered a new ip
because it's sims but it's a very new
take on this well that wouldn't be new
if it was sims yeah
fair enough
but we'll see i mean they you know maxis
obviously tragically shut down last year
but a lot of that stuff had been brought
i mean they have that sims team which is
based i think then in red yeah they seem
to bring a lot of people
from what i remember yeah but i mean
like the sims 4 doesn't seem to be
getting the support like the sims one
two and three did like it didn't seem
getting the expansion packs it doesn't
seem to be getting it is it's getting
expansions but it's really it's like the
base game is the problem yeah it's like
there there are expansions which are
bringing back elements that gamers
wanted to see but the problem is they
took them out
and now they're bringing them back it's
not like you know when you played the
sims 2 and you would get like pets
university yeah you know you're not like
big huge expansions this is filling in
the stuff that they scouched out
piecemeal yeah i mean that's the problem
when you keep adding to the game and
then people expect it all the next year
yeah i'm guessing we won't see any sim
city stuff it seems like city skylines
yeah i'd say that's about right uh
aren't ea doing hazelite yes you're
right i'm dying to see more of that game
i'm not sure if it's too soon because of
course we did get like we've got like
two minutes of it a guy in a train but
that game is made by a bunch of the team
who made brothers tale too so
one of my favorite games ever yeah so
that was all we saw last year was it was
like a
video of a dude in the back of a train
like yeah it was like a little diary it
was a dev diary and then it was like a
couple of guys silhouetted in a train
yeah with a big moon and so no idea what
that game's going to be but i trust the
team behind it so i'm yeah brothers was
great very redundant title but a great
game
yeah do you think that criterion's going
to make an appearance
right that's a good question because
they're god i would love another burnout
just bring back burnout they're working
on
and like an
action sports like what's the word i'm
looking for not actually extreme sports
actions action sports um but that again
that was like a concept arty
here's the devs in the studio behind the
scenes video a couple years ago
god wouldn't another skate game be great
it doesn't matter
goodness yeah danny so do you know about
it before oh god i want it
so there's this brilliant thing that's
been happening on ea's instagram for
like the past six months
where no matter what they post people
flood it with like what we're skate four
like everything
consistently i'm happy with that desire
is there but that's kind of annoying
just kind of because i know that game
like i i will post stuff on our site in
the comments be like what about this
other unrelated thing and i'm like i
just spent all day writing this please
care about the thing i posted so i feel
that community manager's pain but yeah i
also want skate for so and so apparently
i think it was maybe last week ea came
out and said we're like you know like
you know we're happy with all the love
and support for our skate game but
nothing's in development right now
um i guess ea black box made that i'm
not sure i don't think they exist
anymore
so i mean those games are really popular
there became a time like i interviewed
tony hawk downstairs last year where it
there just wasn't enough people buying
those games for both those games to
exist and they almost sort of like
cannibalized each other so i mean tony
hawk's not going anywhere well tony
hawk's not coming back any time soon
they kind of shot themselves in the foot
though i mean like they had a chance
they had the right idea with the most
recent tony hawk like going back to
arcade roots and just
kind of dropped the ball it'd be
interesting to see if ea were like
holding off to see what the reception at
tony hawk right it would be like before
deciding
yeah i mean you could cut that either
way you could either say that was a
complete disaster but i mean you're
right like the game on paper was good it
was just a terrible terrible execution
yeah and so we're running over the arrow
but he aced love and started yet
presumably they're having to change
their press conference because they've
leaked everything i hope they own it i
hope they just make a joke about it i
think everyone will be able to yeah like
you can't just pretend like it didn't
happen right you can't be mad about it
yeah the best way to do is be like haha
right guys okay anyways moving along so
you know hopefully they'll handle it
gracefully but i guess we'll see i can't
imagine peter moore would do would just
completely ignore it i like pia pia wood
it's not his first rodeo what's the over
under on a new peter moore tattoo this
year what do you think it's gonna be
it's been long enough since what was the
last one halo 2
well i think you got the gta 4 one
after that right oh yeah it must have
been off really oh yeah oh no halo 2
james come out
in the comments we'll let us know how
wrong we are thanks everyone for doing
our jobs for us were there any questions
that i don't know if anybody was asking
anybody i'm keeping an eye on it all
right i got it he's not he's gonna
control uh what do we got for ea bingo
what's going to come up what should we
have on our bingo sheets
people who don't have to do with their
hands
okay
supercar on stage yeah we're going to
have uh some kind of sports star who
none of us know who they are or pele
i forgot about paddy for 30 minutes last
year
right danny this is only an hour long
though i think it's gonna be halfway
that's what it felt like half an hour
sports and it still won't be enough um
what else are they gonna have andrew
wilson will be dressed impeccably yes
there will be lightsabers some will have
a lightsaber at some point yeah um
the star wars the star wars will be
pursued star wars music will blend
yeah how many star wars games let's do
it right now how many do you think i'm
gonna go with okay i'll go last i'm
gonna go two i'm gonna say they're gonna
be two separate stories conservative bet
three three i want to go three two wait
does three included like dlc or anything
yeah i'm not even thinking about it
cause i'm sure they're gonna talk about
battlefield two
yeah i think two is a safe bet
three
me and you jess we're in it together
yeah no high five you but we're live
we're all in two now i was gonna go four
if you went three but i'm happy sitting
on three of those you're gonna one up
i'll all go through that i'm good
um a couple of uh questions in here
about maybe some sort of new command and
conquer it's been a little while
yeah i mean
are they i feel like ea's very much in
the console business so like they don't
seem to be making many pc games these
days and i can't imagine a console-based
command and conquer they had that
free-to-play one a couple of years back
which one was that
wait i thought it was a red alert free
to play thing wasn't it is that the one
that they made and then the candidates
i remember playing it really behind the
clothes behind us all the gamescom once
and then they were just like oh yeah no
yubi had uh uh tom clancy's end war
right that was the thing they had rules
as well
yes
yeah but ea it's been quite a long time
since we've seen an rts out of them i
don't know that would be that would be
an interesting one yeah uh mon monvienne
saying john boyega boyega on stage
please oh yes i would love to have
celebrity appearance i don't know
you know star wars games you think they
might well he was yeah because he was
like there needs to be
like he he expressed uh disappointment
at battlefront right really yeah yeah
off the company line john he was like um
why is there no single player yeah the
key wanted
like he was you know he was looking to
maybe bring a little voice acting
right wounds will be healed everything's
going to be fine clever boy uh
can we get fifa star wars with pele as
lando
raging
that foreign will be an outtake some
some year years from now of our
conversation on the couch the whole star
wars fifa the whole chat is saying skate
4.
good job chat yeah
um
what about dead space well the visceral
are working on a star wars game they're
busy they're busy listening also dead
space three was not great no it was not
great dizzy's two is fantastic though i
love dead space tv and even space one
has its marriage your threes that's
baseball is a classic i don't have
anything else yeah about that but your
your three games are always a little bit
like you know it's like uncharted three
it was a little like it was two was
great and the three was
yeah
the same thing
yeah three was going to breeze a little
bit of room to breathe i mean dead space
it feels like we haven't dead dead face
origins like we're all oh no didn't they
do like a wii game that was a prequel is
that a thing or am i making that up i
feel like there was a dead space v game
that wasn't just a port it was like its
own it was like an on-rails computer
that was a prequel i swear this is a
real thing dead space extraction oh
there it is boom yeah 2009. i'm not
crazy so i mean well i mean
unrelated so the other thing is that
like
we're this is like a lot of these
franchises haven't been on the new
consoles yet yeah so even though like a
couple of years past you like maybe
you've got that added element coming in
uh what if we see like a dead space
collection or something yeah i was going
to say
that even
ea won't do remasters right don't do
that well even if they do they won't be
on stage today like they're not going to
be touting a remaster at the press
conference i would have to imagine right
that's not a very sexy thing to spend
their one hour of pressed conference
time
so that's the other thing as well
is that but if that was the case then
they might keep that for the hardware
for yeah that would be like the sony
microsoft press conference thing because
that's the other thing is that ea won't
be done after today this will be like
you know they're sort of top shelf stuff
but they're going to keep a lot of this
stuff for tomorrow's press conferences
because i remember last year the wasn't
it like the weird thing that they
brought to press conferences was plants
vs zombies
like that was the big thing that they
had yeah was there an exclusivity thing
happening there
first or they got first dlc or something
like that
um the original game had timed
exclusivity on xbox one right yeah and
then it came to ps4 later and it was on
pc as well yes
so the other thing they might trot on a
little bit about because they certainly
won't be doing much at the consoles is
ea access
which has i mean i was even surprised by
just how many games were on that service
ahead of time i mean last year was lots
of sports games but like even mirrors
dragon age
right they've been improving it um oh
yeah the battlefield one trailer has the
xbox logo so i assume there's going to
be some kind of exclusivity
there it seems like if microsoft haven't
got caught anymore and they don't have
battlefront they might be grasping for
other right well it's been such an
outpouring of goodwill towards
battlefield it seems like that would
actually politically just be a good
maneuver for them oh yeah
yeah i mean on a lot of these games they
might show campaign here and then
multiplayer yeah at the you know yeah
in years past with call of duty
especially they'll be like the teaser
for like here's what the game is and
then you get to the microsoft press
conference and here's multiplayer or
here's zombies or whatever um so yeah
it's entirely possible that's what
happened today as well or over the next
two days among all these various this
gauntlet or press conferences yeah i
mean by the time tuesday is finished
we're actually gonna know most of the
stuff that's that's yeah gonna be shown
yeah the show will be over before it
begins this year
it's a bit nice so what is this day
minus two minus one at least and then
tomorrow's like day zero it's gonna be
interesting to see
like how much time they allow for
because we've talked about so many games
right it's like maybe multiple star wars
games battlefield one titanfall we
talked about well you know we'll
probably get they have to you know get
people out there so like you might see
amy hennig out there talking a little
while cool and jade raymond might be out
there as well yeah and
you know the haze like game maybe if
they show that they also have to dip you
know into the sports stuff then there's
going to be dlc
for all of the stuff that's already come
out what do you think we're going to see
in that respect in dlc battlefront for
sure oh they've got to show it yeah
because they already have a
game road map laid out so we kind of
know what's coming but i'm sure that
they'll show it like here's this and
then we haven't really had a problem
that's later this year and just details
yeah so i'm sure like that's kind of a
given um yeah what else everyone's
shouting for pele and for the thing to
start
pele riding a skateboard introducing
skate four boom jensey havoc asking for
an ea rugby game yeah
those are rugby games come out every
year they're always just maybe it's a
lacrosse game mike maherty review the
lacrosse game casey powell lacrosse yep
the thing what's it covered i think he
gave him forward what might be
interesting to see is that like
obviously gamescom
is really putting itself more on the map
more in terms of big game releases and
stuff so it could be that they have a
very dedicated number of games just a
few a handful for e3 and then they save
more
like especially i think the ones that
are coming later maybe mass effect for
example would have more of a presence at
gamescom i was so surprised last year
about how much stuff was really shown
there like scalebound we got that big
gameplay reveal like even now it sounds
like sony are sort of coming back yeah
well yeah
escape speaker baby yeah exactly you're
not showing neo or ps4.5 whatever right
e3 where are they gonna maybe it's got
to be gamescom or maybe tgs but then tgs
has fallen by the wayside as well
i would i would be surprised if
microsoft showed anything at tgs but
gamescom they definitely had such a big
presence there last year yeah but
probably well because sony wasn't there
and i mean this year there's a decent
amount of space between that and pax
prime or pax west as it's called now
actually yeah they've been branded yeah
so there's so many events all year long
though you've got you know comic-con and
pax and games common i think tgs is
actually right before comic-con in the
middle of the summer right it's i might
have my dates wrong but there's just so
many big so who knows man who knows it
used to be like everything was e3 and
now it seems like a lot of the big
announcements are spread more evenly
throughout the years i mean even like
during the like the amount of press
conferences we had last week
that leaked
oh yeah yeah we got plenty of leaks to
talk about over the next couple of
weekends yeah and we're sticking to ea
have they still not started here's a
good one dead space vr says don james
2015. potentially i mean i know that
somebody's doing i've actually seen
their um oh galvo's the the game from
last year the cheeser and adventure
horror yes this is the until dawn yeah
they have there's an until danvier game
so you know oh rush of blood yeah yeah
yeah it's an on rails thing so i would
kind of like to do a more exploration
based vr jump scare it's an on rail
shooter isn't it
yeah you should stuff i mean yeah it's
not like you're playing you know area 51
or like time crisis in an arcade or
something but but yeah you're like in a
mine cart and you have a gun and things
jump out at you um so it would be really
cool if we got like an until dawn or
sorry a dead space like exploration
they're pretty good at that whole eye
removal thing as well oh god no i could
work out on vr yeah i think uh mary kish
did a really great like glorious moments
in games competition and that was that
was certainly in there
it's horrifying
um here's a good one i really like my
eyeballs i don't like the idea of them
being gouged out by a space needle pat's
fan 365 pele vr
lav yeah
oh all right let's let's pelevr it's
coming up we just got
got ears on it uh ea is just starting
off so make sure you stick around after
this where we'll be doing our post show
impressions but until then enjoy the
electronic artists
welcome everyone
welcome to ea play coming to you live
from the novo in los angeles
it's always cool to be part of something
new
this is a brand new event
a brand new venue and we're kicking
things off with a new type of show
now we all know you have an insatiable
appetite to dive deep into the games you
love
but we could never give you everything
you want in 60 minutes and let's be
honest even if we could you'd also
probably rather see and hear it from the
community anyway we get it
so consider this next hour to be a taste
a quick glimpse into a bunch of great
stuff that we have in development this
is us opening up the door welcoming in
our players influencers media and
partners we're inviting you in to play
we're surrounded here by hundreds of
game stations thousands of you will get
hands on with our games this week
unfortunately more of you won't
but the content creators here are the
ones who can tell you what they see
what they feel what they like
and even what they don't
and that's fine too we want your
feedback we want to know what you think
just as long as you take some time to
play
of course ea play is a global experience
so here's a twist
someone had this crazy idea of hosting
ea play not one but two locations
and then i'm pretty sure it was that
same person had an even crazier idea of
seeing if we could join them live at via
satellite
so let's welcome peter moore and
hundreds of our friends from london
we're good we're good hi andrew
as you can hear we've got a great crowd
here in london we're at the iconic
hammersmith apollo theater we've got a
hundred game stations back there i've
got 600 of my best friends what a great
looking group they are we are gonna have
a blast tonight back to you
thanks
peter we'll be back with you in just a
bit let's quickly set the stage for what
you'll see over the next hour we will
take a look into the future of ea star
wars games
bioware will take us further into the
next intense chapter of the mass effect
universe
from ea sports we have both competition
and story
and of course battlefield 1 and
titanfall 2 are both here today
right away after this show we will
actually host the first ever
live-streamed 64-player battlefield 1
match
now here's a question for you did any of
you see the battlefield trailer last
month
i know you did and i know a bunch of you
were thinking is this real
are there actually going to be airships
and horses and trench knives and shovels
so two things one yes
and two you can see it for yourselves
not in another trailer but with an hour
of gameplay live streamed around the
world just an hour from now
a few thoughts before we get into the
action
just a decade ago there are about 200
million game players in the world we
thought that was a lot
now there are 2.6 billion and growing
we are all part of a global phenomenon
at its core is play something that is
increasingly important to our lives
today
for many of us games are vital
that's what drives us to make games and
continue building creating innovating
and exploring
we know just how important it is
we see it as our responsibility to help
people on all corners of the globe
experience play
because we all play to live this will be
a fantastic three days so let's get
started first up is a great friend and
the mastermind behind one of the
industry's most compelling franchises
vincent bella
thank you andrew
well everyone it's great to be back near
e3
um so
titanfall introduced millions of players
around the world to the fast fluid pilot
and titan gameplay that is at the heart
of titanfall and with the release of
titanfall 2 we're excited to welcome ps4
players to the franchise for the first
time
uh we'll start off with a look at what
players can expect out of titanfall
multiplayer
let's do this
welcome back
ah
me
2013
oh
i love it
so
titanfall 2 builds on the signature
pilot and titan gameplay to deliver a
more robust experience
backed by the depth and variety our fans
have been asking for this includes six
new titans each with their own unique
combat abilities expanded pilot gameplay
more customization options and a deep
progression system and of course super
smooth gameplay that we've always
delivered
prior to launch we'll be holding a
multiplayer technical test designed to
help us stress key features of the game
to play the multiplayer test go to
titanfall.com and sign up to get all the
details
now for the four people that didn't see
the leak this morning
and if you know this sing along with me
i'm excited to confirm single player
so we'll be adding a full offline
playable campaign to titanfall 2.
it'll be crafted to dive deeper into the
titanfall universe exploring the unique
bond between pilot and titan taking full
advantage of the movement in combat to
deliver a feeling of being unstoppable
together
and now here is the debut of the single
player trailer for titanfall 2 coming
october 28th to ps4 xbox one and pc
thank you everyone
bt 7274
your data recorder says your original
pilot was killed in action
correct
my original pilot was kia
i am now linked to rifleman jack cooper
who authorized this
we had no other options
what are your protocols
protocol one
link to pilot
protocol 2
uphold the mission
protocol 3.
protect the pilot
stand by for titanfall
trust me
welcome to denver i'm brandon gardner
alongside charles davis as the 2016 nfl
season is underway
is
here we go just three seconds left the
broncos fighting for their playoff lives
tj ward blocked it into the most
improbable of
denver is going to the playoffs
that is madden nfl 17 for playstation 4
and xbox one and as always the game
looks incredible this year madden lets
you take your team all the way with the
most balanced gameplay today
new ways to play in franchise mode and
an all-new commentary team it
personifies everything we love about
sports passion
intensity
and of course competition
competition in the world of gaming is
esports and it's absolutely electric
elite players
a global stage and of course big paydays
from the first madden challenge 14 years
ago to today's competitive battlefield
scene and of course the fifa interactive
world cup ea is no stranger to the power
of elite competition but the spectacle
of esports barely scratches the surface
of competition
it's a select few that become pro gamers
that is why ea is embracing a new
approach to competitive gaming we want
to make stars of all of our players
with new competitive modes and weekly
online contests in our biggest
franchises we're making competition fun
and meaningful for everyone regardless
of their ability as such i'm not excited
to announce three awesome new ways to
compete challenge your events
premiere events and ea major events with
our challenger series of events we'll be
giving the community an ability to be
more easily hosting and running their
own tournaments
next up is the premiere series these are
large-scale live events that we'll host
with partners from inside and outside of
the gaming world
and finally there are ea major events
these are marquee live events run by ea
on a global stage the best players
competing for the biggest prizes and it
all starts this weekend at ea play in
los angeles with our first ea major
event the madden nfl 16 championship
in a moment we'll welcome espn's stan
barrett to the stage in la who will
introduce you to the eight finalists
but first let's meet two of the fiercest
madden competition out there
eric problem right and zach
sirius moe lane
the greatest of all time he is the guy
to beat this guy just wins
being the best in the world often
inspires all reverence respect
but when you're the best in the world at
a video game everyone thinks they can
take you down
every day on twitter there's people
coming in saying that they can beat me
usually i just respond in in the nature
of something like you know floyd
mayweather doesn't fight you know joe
smo off the streets i am the greatest of
all time when it comes to madden
football i'm here to win and whoever's
in the way is just you know another
person that's going to have to get laid
out
i'd like to believe that i'm the best
mountain player in the world give it up
for serious mo
if anybody can be the hair the problem's
thrown a lot of people feel it's going
to be serious mouth i kind of dedicated
my life to this you know i mean when i
was 16 i was like at the top of my class
but i would like go to school with like
no sleep from being up all night playing
being a full-time video game player
is hard for a lot of people to
understand
it is tough it's tough to do and i'll
play as many hours as i can just to
really get ahead of the competition
both problem and serious mo have a claim
to the top of the madden world and the
issue may be settled at the madden
championship it's a tournament that
started with a million players and
online qualifiers and ends this week
live in los angeles with 50 thousand
dollars at stake
these would-be rivals are actually close
friends but don't expect them to take it
easy on each other if they meet with a
title on the line oh there's no question
i'm going to win the madden challenge
this time around i wish him the best
luck but you know i gotta beat him
it started with a million players
competing online and now
only these eight remain the best madden
nfl players in the world
all world-class competitors they're at
the top of their game
but only one is going to be the winner
uh let's let's meet one of the guys here
who appears to be a little injured this
is serious mo you saw in the piece what
happened i was racing a friend then had
my shoes tied fell down broke my
collarbone
didn't have your shoes tied
are they tied now
no
no they're not tied all right we don't
want you to fall off the stage
all right best of luck to you best of
luck to all of you guys now it's going
to be an awesome competition if you
can't be here at ea play to see it in
person you can tune in you can watch on
twitch youtube or tune into espn3 to
watch all the action live or join us at
espn2 6 pm eastern on tuesday for the
finals now let's send it back to peter
in london
thank you stan looking forward to some
great action this week but let's also
take a moment to talk about the year
ahead i'm excited to announce the madden
nfl 17 championship series next year
everything gets bigger and better how
much better we're putting up one million
dollars in total prize money now it
takes full-time dedication to be the
best and we want to reward our elite
players for their skill and commitment
the madden 17 championship series is a
full year of high-stakes action
that spans four ea majors and more
events to be announced soon but it's not
just madden at ea competition is at the
heart of everything we'll do
and we'll have more news about more
events and more games to share soon so
stay tuned and here's to a great year of
competition ahead but now let's go back
to los angeles he's the general manager
of bioware my good friend aaron flynn
thank you peter thank you
thank you everybody thank you um
at the heart of mass effect andromeda is
a question
how far will we go
in the game you are part of an ambitious
expedition leaving the milky way galaxy
to help humanity find a new home
you travel millions of light years to
the andromeda galaxy you wake up
now what
everything is new new planets new
species new technologies
you must be among the most courageous
the most daring to go on this journey
because this is a galaxy where you are
the alien
how far will we go
that question is also at the heart of
the development of mass effect andromeda
the mass effect trilogy is a huge part
of our history and the lives of many of
our fans
it was an amazing story but this
is a whole new adventure
we're building on the things you love
about mass effect
amazing stories and gameplay and now
we're letting our imaginations run wild
this is a bigger adventure filled with a
whole new cast of memorable characters
and more freedom than we've ever given
players in a bioware game
and for the first time it's all powered
by frostbite which means you're going to
see
hear and feel mass effect like never
before
that's our promise to you
so how far will we go
we can't wait to share more with you
this fall
here's a look behind the scenes at mass
effect andromeda thank you
our survival as a species
has always depended on our drive to seek
out the undiscovered
push beyond our limits
and expand the boundaries of our known
world
with mass effect we are going further
than ever before
to andromeda
to build a new home for humanity
imagine distant star systems with remote
hostile planets
teeming with alien life and
civilizations
worlds where adventure
danger
and the unknown are waiting to be
discovered
we've created a universe that you will
lose yourself in a whole new galaxy for
you to explore
uh
we made it
right
how's everyone doing
okay
i hope you're loving what you've seen so
far we've still got a bunch more ahead
including fifa star wars and of course
battlefield 1.
but first let's have a practical
conversation about play
many of these games we're talking about
today are months away meanwhile i'm sure
you're all playing games that you've
already invested a ton of time in
so our commitment to is to support the
community it's a commitment to continue
delivering new content to enjoy with
your friends
in just the last year alone we delivered
more than 300 game updates to our most
popular games
this year that number will be even
higher
and for ea play this week we have our
biggest collection of content updates
ever across both console pc and mobile
we've also got free trials to help you
discover and try something new this week
like the outer rim expansion for star
wars battlefront
or check out some new games through ea
access for xbox one and origin access
for pc
both have more than 20 great games
available in the vault and they are free
for everyone to try
all week long
now here's one more way we hope you'll
play this week we have a new program
called play to give
it's a big deal for us and it's unlike
anything we've ever done before we're
bringing together in-game challenges
with charitable donations
first the charities at ea we celebrate
charitable causes that encourage a more
diverse and inclusive world for all of
us as well as those that inspire and
assist future game makers through stem
education
so we've partnered with five great
organizations for ea play
the un he for she initiative
national center for women and
information technology
special effects
code.org
and code 2040.
now the challenges
there are five of them that are designed
to celebrate our player community this
week some examples in battlefield 4 and
battlefield hardline there's a new
objective that's based on helping out
your teammates in need
we're celebrating strong female
characters in star wars galaxy of heroes
as you deploy a special squad to battle
against the droids and in fifa ultimate
team if you can win with the play to
give cup you'll receive an untradable
rare mega pack
it all comes together at the end of ea
play when we donate one million dollars
in celebration of the importance of play
now let me send it back to peter for
some big news on fifa 17. peter over to
you
let me check how's everyone doing
i think we're winning
thanks andrew and welcome back to london
now like me i know many of you are
excited that we're in the middle of a
summer full of football
england looked good last night
till about the 92nd minute
um but to be here in england at the
heart of football there's no better
place to show you what's next
you'll see in a moment just how far fifa
has come from its debut in 1993
this is a revolutionary year for fifa
for the most popular sports game on the
planet
this is fifa 17.
e a sports in the game
but you will
my name is alex hunter
and just like you and every other kid
that's grown up kicking about a football
i've always dreamed of playing on the
biggest stage for the best tactical
minds in the game alongside the greatest
names
playing in the park with my mates
i've already pictured it
taking flawless 50-yard passes from
beckham sending him messi with the
perfect through ball
burying it in the top corner like rooney
now
i have the chance to make that dream
my reality
to pull on a premier league shirt and
maybe even one day step into the center
circle of wembley three lions on my
chest
this
is the start of my journey
i know it won't be easy
but if i can perform on the pitch make
the right decisions off it and take
advantage of every opportunity that
comes my way
this
is the start of my journey
and you're all coming with me
we've heard a lot about the talent of
this young man alex hunter
he had a wide choice of clubs to sign
for today his journey begins as he makes
his premier league debut
i haven't seen a kid coming out of the
exit trials generate this much interest
in years
i never expected anything like this
yes a goal for alex hunter on his debut
you're in the big league now you have to
raise your game you need representation
you call me
wow
check this place out
just don't get too carried away
can disappear just like that
life doesn't always give you what you
want does it
i'm ready
you'll get your opportunity hunter
just get me out there
oh he might as well pack this seasoning
now
what was he thinking
i want to stay and fight for my place
i won't let you down
alex hunter an outstanding goal
welcome to the premier league this young
man has everything we're going to make
history incredible hunter
my name is alex hunter
you don't know me
but believe me you soon will
so that's amazing
what you just saw is a brand new
experience
in fifa 17 called the journey
you'll live your premier league story
through the player we just met
alex hunter that is the power of
frostbite fifa 17's brand new engine
you'll live in real football worlds and
you'll meet characters full of depth
and emotion
and maybe nobody shows more emotion than
the managers on the sidelines
and as such for the first time ever
premier league managers are in the game
so that means if we're launched today
we'd have three of the most legendary
managers in fifa 17 check them out
pep guardiola set to join the league the
legendary arsene wenger at arsenal
and of course my favorite them all at
the best club in the world
jurgen klopp at liverpool
now these managers are the best these
three are the best second to none
more than 1500 wins between them with
ten league championships and two
did i say three i'm not quite sure
ladies and gentlemen jose mourinho
so i apologize i i don't write the
scripts here i don't do the game
jose of course is in the game and it is
a great honor for jose to join the ea
family to be in fifa 17 as the great
manager now of course of manchester
united we've rendered you in the game i
don't know uh if we can have a look can
we get it can we get jose up in the game
but i'm i'm still upset with you
you're still upset what about you are
you going to be more upset when you come
to anfield this season we are we are 20
of us you choose three
just three you leave us
17 out i know
that yeah see that clint
first of all he looks great secondly i
can tell you on behalf of all of us
football fans it's great having the
personality and the skill and the talent
that is jose mourinho back in the
premier league and thirdly i can't wait
to bring them to manfield and show them
where real football is played having
said that
having said that it is great having you
in the game i know your son's a big
player
yes he is who does he play us here's the
question do you know
i don't know really i just know that
i can wake up three four o'clock in the
morning with his noise
does he spend money on ultimate team
that you're aware of yeah i control the
debit cards and yes
well i think we've all seen your
contract so i think there's plenty of
ultimate team business to be had
so it's going to be great having the
managers in there and it's even more
important to have jose mourinho one of
the great personalities of football for
the last 20 years and all of the things
that he's done for this game we couldn't
be more happy to have you in the game i
know your son needs some early code for
the game i think i can take care of that
so but ladies and gentlemen please thank
jose mourinho for joining us here
welcome bye
thank you
i didn't call him the special one he
doesn't like it
okay we've shown you a lot today but
we're not done it is my pleasure to
introduce you to fifa producer aaron
mccarty aaron
thank you peter
it's great to be here in london
uh but for me and for the development
team back in vancouver it's amazing to
finally be able to show you the journey
now the best thing about the journey is
you're in control of your story off the
pitch
but in fifa
just like football the most important
thing is what happens on the pitch and
that's especially true in game play
we're bringing complete innovation to
the game this season
we've got four big transformations that
let you own every moment
and we're bringing more control than
ever before here they are
we've rewritten set pieces to give you
creative control over every dead ball
we completely overhauled physical play
we built a new intelligence system so
our players are smarter and more active
off the ball
and we're giving you new ways to create
chances and finish in front of goal
and those massive transformations are
inspired by some of the best young
football talent in the game
let's meet them now through the lens of
fifa 17.
okay guys a new season
a fresh start
today
is about winning
in football this is the most important
thing
when we win we make the fans happy
they arrive with training
they are why we are here
so remember
what we need to do
be strong on the ball
make intelligent runs
be ruthless in front of goal
and own every moment
the time has come
you are ready
the fans are ready
now go show them why we are the best
great strength
hard and low
that is world class from james rodriguez
make them happy
make them sing your name
when you play for the fans
that is when we win
so about this time last year we
surprised you with something unexpected
with unravel you met yarny a tiny little
character with a huge heart going on an
epic adventure
you also met martin saline a passionate
and creative game maker from the cold
war studio that brought johnny to life
we knew unravel would steal your hearts
because it's stole ours
but it also showed us something profound
when we first saw unravel we saw a game
that we knew deserved the world's
attention it deserved to be played
we also know that there are more out
there more studios like coldwood more
games like unravel
passionate developers telling amazing
stories creating spectacular games
we are committed to working with small
developers finding these great new games
and giving all of you a chance to
discover their magic
so today we are very excited to announce
ea originals
our ea originals program is about three
things
firstly it's about taking first-time
experiences that are unique
gorgeous innovative and memorable and
bringing them to the world
secondly it's about supporting small
developers and help helping them make
the most of their games
now we'll seek out a few projects each
year for e-originals and partner with
them to the whole process from
development to marketing to publishing
and lastly it's about funding and
offering a level of security now making
games is hard it's a hard business
and these small developers have risked
themselves to develop a new ip and
created games
deserved and great games to serve to be
played
now check this out with ea originals we
want all the profit from these games to
go back into the hands of the developers
so they can keep innovating and creating
into the future
now we've already begun with ea
originals so please welcome to our stage
claus lingard from zoing games in
gothenburg he is here to take you into
the beautiful world of our first ea
originals game called the fear
hi everyone wow it's amazing to be here
joining you all at ea play here in los
angeles it's uh well it's really huge
for me and i'm super excited to be here
i run a small game studio in sweden in
gothenburg coldzoink
and we're about 20 people brought
together by our fascination for new
approaches to interactive storytelling
and art
and recently we've been on a journey
with a very special new project
and thanks to patrick and ea
we're here today to bring you along with
us
let me introduce you to the world of
fee
at its heart faye is a personal
narrative about our relationship with
nature it's a game without words
a celebration of our longing to be one
with the world around us
it's a story that reminds us that
everything in this world is connected
living in a delicate balance that is
constantly under threat
you awaken as a young cop all alone in a
dark forest glade
and you have no idea who you are or how
you got there
but as you spy from the treetops you'll
soon come to know the extraordinary
creatures that live in this forest
and you'll find that they are all
connected through their own language
a language of strange and beautiful
music
see every animal every breathing
creature and even the plants
they all have their own unique song
and by learning them you can connect to
the forest to understand it
to be part of it
each song you learn
will help you reach new parts of the
forest
and take you ever closer to discovering
the secret of your own kind
but you are not the only newcomer to the
forest
the silent ones corrupt the forest and
spread their silence with each step
as you evade them using stealth and
cunning you will uncover their terrible
purpose
this is a game full of discovery
conflict and relationships
as you explore the world of faith
we're not going to hold your hand
the game won't tell you where to go what
to do or how to think
we will set the stage and invite you
into the forest for your own personal
experience
an experience that will leave you scared
amazed and delighted
in the forest your discoveries will be
your own
i'm very proud to show you more about
the beautiful world of fee
thank you
hey
hi everyone it's great to be here to
talk about our star wars games
right now we have teams across the world
creating a wide range of star wars games
for all types of star wars fans
these teams are being led by some of the
creative minds who have made some of our
favorite games of the last decade
and now they're channeling their talent
and passion to bring you all new
experiences that will span many corners
of the star wars universe for years to
come
let's break it down
already today you can play star wars
galaxy of heroes
star wars the old republic
and of course star wars battlefront
each of these games are live and getting
fresh
new content all year long
next year you're gonna get a new
installment of star wars battlefront
led by dice in collaboration with motive
we're building on the foundation of the
first game
we're listening to our players
and adding more of what you want
including content from the new films
then coming in 2018
is a new
action-adventure game from visceral
games
amy hennig and team are creating an
original narrative
in the star wars universe with new
characters
and beyond that we've got more amazing
projects in store
including one from our partners at
respawn entertainment
they are exploring a different star wars
era in their own third person action
adventure game
we can't wait for you to play these
games
i can't wait to play them myself
here's a special peek
behind the curtain
at the ea star wars games we're working
on with lucasfilm
thank you and may the force be with you
the star wars universe is growing day by
day with the comics the films the games
you name it and to be a part of that and
to work with lucasfilm is incredibly
exciting
so we're really trying to do at ea is
cater to different areas of the star
wars universe and create different game
experiences they're tailor-made for
those fans
with star wars battlefront we wanted to
really be able to bring people into the
world of star wars like never before
what excites me now is bringing in more
characters more planets more
environments more eras
and that's why we're super happy to have
both motive studios and criterion
contributing in significant ways
there's no point in making something in
the star wars ip if you're just going to
do what's been done before right so it's
a fantastic opportunity for motive to
really tell the world what we're about
and we're going to bring that to
battlefront which is it's crazy it's
incredible
as a studio our promise to gamers is
ultimately game play first
we all demand that the game has these
huge wow moments that translates really
well into the star wars universe
we're gonna deliver that star wars awe
like fans have never seen before
with star wars galaxy of heroes we
talked a lot about how we grew up as
kids with star wars and we collected
toys we'd bring them over to a friend's
house and we'd set up these battles
where sometimes it was what we'd seen in
the films and sometimes it was just a
random mashup of stuff that we wanted to
play from our own imagination our aim is
to bring in characters from all the
films all the tv shows and even beyond
star wars is what got me into role
playing games in the first place that
storytelling you did as a kid with your
your star wars action figures
with star wars the old republic the
choices you make the freedom you have
that's really at the heart of a bioware
game and beyond the old republic there
are so many stories that we still want
to tell
our goal has always been not to just
sort of make a game that is set in the
star wars universe but to really tell an
authentic star wars story and that's
actually a hugely different thing
how do you ground
the new and unfamiliar and the familiar
you need the guidance of someone like
doug chang to show you the way
one of the great joys of working with
amy is she is like a film director in
many ways because she is telling her
story and i'm helping to realize her
world
ea has some really exciting plans in the
works for the star wars portfolio and
what we're doing is bringing in talent
from across the industry and letting
them loose
we have completely different games on
the horizon and i just hope that every
fan walks away going wow i never thought
they were going to bring my star wars
fantasy to life
thank you jade and thank you to all our
studio teams working on star wars games
today
so
here we are one last game
let's talk battlefield 1.
you might be wondering why i'm up here
again well my journey with battlefield
started over two decades ago when dice
was still a small indie studio
we were dreaming about conquering the
world and sharing our games with more
and more players
now i've been involved in each and every
part of this series and it's humbling to
serve a battlefield community today that
has grown to more than 60 million
players around the world that is truly
incredible so thank you
it also means that we have a great
responsibility to deliver on the promise
of battlefield with every game
we have to take creative risks
to pioneer
so we knew from the start that
battlefield 1 could be no ordinary game
now let me tell you a quick story about
the inception of battlefield one
a few years ago two guys in our studio
in dyson stockholm stefan stanberg and
martin copperhead kept telling me that
they had the concept for the next
battlefield
and each time we met they showed me more
and more ideas from the team
now i'll be honest i was skeptical i was
like really skeptical
and i told them that i don't think we
have it yet
but they kept pushing they kept coming
back and then one late night in
stockholm they brought me a very special
pitch
an absolutely mind-boggling pitch
unmistakably battlefield and set in a
very unique take on world war one
right then and there that's when we knew
we had to make this game
so when you stand here introducing a
game like battlefield 1 to tens and
millions of dedicated players you know
the risks were worth it
behind
we can't change the world
so that was just a piece of our ea play
trailer and you'll get to see the full
version in just a bit but first i want
you to know that our team at dyson
stockholm has huge ambitions for
battlefield 1. we've set out to deliver
an epic and unforgettable experience for
our players and the result is a dynamic
experience where no battle is ever the
same
but as a talented as our dice team is it
is you the battlefield community that
powers the team
that is why at world premiere last month
we revealed battlefield 1 alongside our
players
we want the community to be part of this
every step of the way
and today marks another exciting
milestone in the road to battlefield one
our first in-depth look at gameplay
and to reveal that i'm honored that we
have players from our community here to
lead the first ever live stream of
battlefield 1 immediately following the
press conference and our host jose
sanchez is with a few of them right now
thanks guys i am excited because today
we are going to see actual gameplay
straight
from battlefield one under the command
of two solid teams with players like
jamie foxx zac efron are gonna be on
those team are you guys pumped for
tonight's events
yes
jazz can't wait dude stoked
i know i'm excited and coming up in a
few minutes we have the battlefield
squads live stream kicking off 64
players going head to head 32 v 32 in a
best of three match up and i can't wait
to see wins good luck to the both of you
guys and your respective teams now let's
go back up to patrick and find out
exactly what makes this game so epic
thank you jose
so only in battle 1 will you engage in
some of the biggest battles ever seen as
you squad up in epic multiplayer matches
with up to 64 players now that's going
to be really cool to watch
and in just a few minutes you'll get to
see how no battle is ever the same
through the power of frostbite intuitive
destruction dynamic weather and a
variety of weapons and vehicles makes
this the most immersive and dynamic
battlefield game ever
so let's start by talking destruction a
hallmark for battlefield
in battlefield 1 destruction is more
intuitive and natural than ever this
creates unlimited gameplay possibilities
as you impact the world around you
and next dynamic weather
weather will now change unpredictably so
you can you will need to adjust your
tactics based on the conditions
so playing the same map on a bright day
or in heavy fog or rain will impact what
you see
or hear so you have to adapt your
playstyle and finally
an impressive variety of weapons and
vehicles add to the range of experience
you'll have on the battlefield
and most notable the introduction of the
ultimate vehicles the behemoths
the great war gave birth to some of the
largest vehicles ever made and
battlefield 1 gives you the chance to
control these beasts
take control of an airship armored train
or a battleship to dominate the
battlefield across air land and sea
an all-out war has never felt so epic
when battlefield 1 launches on october
21st
worldwide you will experience
destruction
weather and a variety of weapons and
vehicles that ensure no battle is ever
the same
and for those of you who are battlefield
insiders you get an early access to
experience this firsthand during the
open beta later this summer
all right
in just a few minutes the battlefield
squads live stream will begin
but first
let's take another look at battlefield
one thank you
you're gonna get us all killed
we can't change the world
thank you boys
okay
right
uh
we're going to change the world indeed
it looks absolutely amazing battlefield
1.
so that's our show we have battlefield 1
playables right behind me here in la in
london we've got titanfall 2 we've got
fifa 17 we've got madden 17. we here in
london gonna have a great time tonight
we're here through midnight it's going
to be phenomenal andrew i'm sure you're
going to have the same there back to you
in los angeles
thanks peter
all right so that's our show
and now the way i see it i'm the only
thing standing between you and an hour
of battlefield 1 gameplay so let's keep
this quick thank you everyone for
joining us today thank you to all of you
here in los angeles and of course thank
you to everyone in london as well we're
just getting started here at ea play so
stay with us there's a lot more to come
and now it's time to play
thank you
if
all right there you go folks that's one
down five to go ea's conference okay
let's all
put up our virtual scoreboards for that
out of ten scott butterworth what do you
want to give electronic art there's not
a lot of surprises there and actually
some stuff that i really wish we'd seen
more of like i really wanted more
andromeda and what we did see was pretty
enticing but it would be great to get
like actual gameplay something like that
yeah so you know a lot of they kind of
played it safe a lot of really expected
announcements
we got six okay generous lucy i'm gonna
go seven no because they had a couple of
really nice things that everyone seemed
to ignore like the ea originals right
they were talking about uh giving money
to charity all that kind of stuff
working with
money to charity working with special
effects um and of course i completely
loved the andromeda and the look at the
fee
faith
but you know that was interesting so
yeah we predicted pretty much all of
that but yeah
we were right about like
yeah like last year's unraveled it's
this year's fee although i like the idea
of that program that they're going to be
expanding that and encouraging i mean
you had your edge a chance jess
scorecard
fair enough um yeah i think it's a hard
seven i i i enjoyed it i i actually
thought i maybe i was more pessimistic i
thought we might see less of andromeda
than what we saw yeah i really liked
everything they said like everything
they said they're working towards for
andromeda is basically like everything
i've got on the wish list like i can't
even think of anything that you know i
wish they'd teased at related to that
game that they didn't um and what we did
see of even if it wasn't you know in
engine gameplay footage looked gorgeous
absolutely good fair enough all right
let's ram through this list of games
everyone is watching on the live stream
they're starting to get that battlefield
uh gameplay event going but they're
going to talk to zac efron and jamie
foxx for about 10 minutes probably so
we'll be done and dusted by the time
that thing started so stick around i'm
jazzed yeah for sure get your questions
in at twitch on the gamespot uh chat as
well uh okay first things first
titanfall 2. yeah yeah
you already seen it that was probably
like of the footage they showed like of
the actual gameplay that we saw during
that press conference that was probably
my my favorite um i mean it was also
arguably the deepest look at any of the
games that they were showing off in star
wars they kind of rolled everything
together but titanfall it's like all
right here's uh two separate trailers
one for multiplayer one for the single
player campaign which we knew about but
now hey it's official we got this big
trailer uh we got the kind of creepy ai
voice over and the sort of hinting at
this relationship between pilots and
mechs which we'd speculated on but now
it's really confirmed and it was nice to
see it in action yeah so the multiplayer
looks great i mean you can see how like
a couple of years as well has really
given this engine a bit of a bit of
breathing room but i like even like that
transitioning at the titans that are
already on the field instead of just
jumping down into them because
they're just really learning a lot like
i mean obviously rhys one's a team
that's proved themselves to be quite
reliable but they also seem to be
massively listening to what their fans
want and stuff like that yeah single
player was like the big ask from last
year this gameplay looks great it looks
like they've been incorporating a lot of
sweet mechanics yeah from overwatch to
change up the yeah
there's tracers there's there's
always
they are
mechanics that are layered on top of the
typical first person shooter
looking stuff sorry we're saying i was
saying yeah yeah
it's okay
um yeah i just i think it looks sweet i
mean that they look like they're you
know delivering on the grappling and
everything like that like they've
already got mobility down as such a
central theme of what titanfall is and
it just seems like they're just
expanding on that so it's like
everything is faster everything is
parkour and movement and skill based and
i don't know
i think i think they got it down i think
they're on the right track it's going to
be interesting what they do with the
single-payer campaign because obviously
in the multiplayer like titanfall is
based on this foundation of you being
able to move better and shoot better
than everyone else uh interested in the
single player aspect of that at all
scott i'm happy that it exists yeah i
mean i was definitely with the chorus of
people saying where's the single player
i mean that's definitely how i like to
play games and i think that there was
you know a lot of lore simmering under
the surface in the first game that you
just kind of you could tell was there
but wasn't you weren't really able to
explore it given that it was a
multiplayer only game so i'm excited
that they're going to be able to really
lean into that stuff and give us more
insight into the universe and it seems
like it's going to lend itself well to
a single player experience so i'm
excited to see what they do with it yeah
coming real soon october 28th on pc ps4
and xbox one uh okay they talked about
esports for about 15 minutes should we
just skip over that
maybe esports that's what it is yeah it
sure is a thing it is i mean it is a
thing it is esports is relevant sports
is relevant to the esports crowd it's
unlike the people who don't like it into
gaming
i don't particularly involve myself in e
yeah personally but i think it is very
relevant and becoming more relevant as
as we move forward year after year i
feel like this is the third or fourth
year where there has esports has had a
big crowd and e3 is just not the place
to spend that's probably true talking
about it i mean the same as e3 isn't
really the place where we hear about pc
games it's right yeah yeah so anyway
let's move on yeah mass effect andromeda
we got a dev dive
well yeah
i think they're just going to hold off
for gamescom it's coming out next year
so they'll want to focus on battlefield
and want to focus on titanfall but i was
really
to be honest i was expecting less
footage i was expecting
just like again the concept art stuff
but what was interesting is that the
concept that they were showing is the
concept that we saw like two years ago
but this time fleshed out characters in
it um better lighting effects more
movement and also first like a
protagonist who
everyone was crying out for fem shep in
the original trilogy to be the face of
the trilogy and it looks like they're
leading with that yeah that's something
that's cool yeah i like that um
the tempest looks an awful lot like the
normandy yeah um but what i kind of like
is because you also got to see a um
a relay is that they're kind of holding
on to the old mass effect and especially
in terms of um
like just the look of it and some of the
keystones like like the um like the
citadel those kind of things and some of
the creatures and races but they aren't
afraid to be injecting new things like
this creature here these new
environments so we get seen asari she's
definitely in there and i think what
looks like a yard which the shadow
broker was
so
it's this real mash-up of old and new
and i am super excited i'm getting the
impression like i think planet
exploration is going to be great i mean
because we know we know the mako's on
board we've known that for a while which
means i'm sure we're going to be back on
the ground again and that's been less of
a focus more on the cities and things
like that um presidium and all that so i
think that's going to be awesome and
just like how dedicated they seem to be
to
uh how alien everything is going to be
ironically that's where they're alien
but i think that's going to be great
we're going to see
less humans we're going to see them
branching out more i think like trying
out you know different themes of planets
different races and just you know they
know they can deep dive into law and
into like just completely invented
spaces and that we're going to lap it up
yeah so i think like because they've got
all that backing we should see some
super good [ __ ] exciting stuff i mean
it'd be great if we saw some more of it
at the microsoft and sony's things
still
uh fifa 17 they showed a bunch of that
as well to a crowd in london who
presumably doesn't really care all that
much about football because the euros
were literally on the germany ukraine
game was on uh it was finishing as fifa
was on so they showed off single-player
stuff you can never tell fifa you know
can we talk about that opening monologue
for a minute that that was unusual that
would which is the jose mourinho thing
yeah oh no it's hunted yeah oh my god
yeah they showed that off i mean the
fifa the journey stuff we don't know how
it ends up will it be
good like the finite champion stuff will
it be not so good like the
2k16 um stuff i don't know we'll have to
we'll have to wait and see at least
they're trying something new i mean it's
yeah fifa's yeah that's interesting but
the first time they've added something
this large into the package in about two
or three years so we'll have to wait and
see uh yeah they'd uh arsene wenger and
jurgen klopp on the screen and then jose
mourinho came out and chatted for a bit
they showed another trailer and then we
were into ea originals
zoink from gothenburg
fair fair this is exactly what we were
talking about you did you called it
before
what ea does and i think it's awesome
and i'm glad that they want to do it as
a whole thing as well like because and
obviously they're recognizing they know
they do that and it's like well i mean
lily you want to make a big deal out of
it
yeah
yeah
so what do we think of it oh it looks
adorable it looks like ahri okay
it's like alright it looks a little bit
like tearaway
um from the original concept yeah from
the concept i thought it looked a little
bit like limbo but obviously now seeing
it in action it's it's obviously purple
and not black and white so i feel like
i've played this game about six times
over the past two years though
yeah we kind of i feel like we're really
getting to the bottom of the well of the
adorable little critters yeah pinging
platformer saying see i yeah i'm yet to
get sick of that right okay
i'm just cynical when it comes to scary
these dudes the big towering guys
they're right obviously the kinda like
the things from recall they're foes yeah
they they're kind of creeping me out so
they go that's fair yeah
the most interestingly named game we've
seen today for sure and then we had star
wars a whole bunch of star wars and they
had galaxy heroes in the old republic
and battlefront and i'm behind him
we're making star wars games did you
know we've already made a bunch
of more unnamed games that will probably
come out in the next couple years yeah
so they didn't name any of these but
they did show
baby glimpses yeah little teasers of
three yeah one two three yeah so i guess
i win by default you do
it new battlefront 2017 uh coming from
motive coming out in 2017 sorry yeah
new action adventure game coming out of
visceral then they had respawns third
person game which they said was in a
different era yeah yeah which could kind
of mean anything i mean there's so
there's a big timeline to work with so
yeah and the whole thing kind of felt
like one of those like paper
announcements where they use this to
like get a lot of talented people to
come and have to make these games at the
dev that we you call that one actually
lucy there was like an x-wing or a tie
fighter in virtual reality yeah no no
that was was that useful
you said either way we would definitely
talk about it and yeah there was a
little glimpse of it just there that
certainly looked like someone in a
headset so that guy there next wing this
guy used to work on far cry 4. right so
it'd be interesting to see if he went
straight from that to um motive or
respawn whatever that was respawns looks
interesting because it's they're they're
all about the lightsaber fights and i'm
instantly thinking oh man i'd love to
play some more jedi multiplayer that guy
watching the lightsaber fights right now
is just really intense
and then yeah they went into capital
games a little bit with what they're up
to up in sacramento um but yeah we saw a
little sneak peak of three seconds of
amy hennig's amy's game looks all right
is that four and it's pretty
well like the marketplace there's like
11.
yeah so many points
um yeah
i'm excited for that let's get some face
time for both amy and jade both like
spearheading huge star wars projects
leading the charge on both of those and
they also sort of said that there was a
bunch more uh content coming to the old
republic and to battlefront and stuff
like that so yeah i mean yea he's making
a lot of star wars video games right yes
and hopefully we'll see some more
gameplay of some of them i just felt a
little bit like oh you you you gave me
another yeah you i got the blue ball you
gave me enough that i can't complain but
like
like at least a little bit of something
yeah like a montage i guess you used too
much
yeah i think it's crossfit visceral but
oh wow yeah we'll see if the next
battlefront will still be multiplayer
focused if there's like the visceral
game kind of handle the single player
side of things right yeah i wonder if
they tip their hat like titanfall have
as well guess we'll have to wait and see
we have to wait to see this little bit
of this three seconds of hot gameplay
action though very important yeah yeah
so everyone just sit quietly
i know right just thinking yeah okay
here we go yeah look at that high
dynamic range
i mean
boom it's real pretty there you go real
pretty very suggested banners waving in
the wind yeah little details you know
yeah and then that was it for star wars
for a little while and patrick brock
came out and they showed
it was kind of weird they showed like a
very short single player like snippet
from the trailer 15 seconds yeah you're
not sure why the fall start there that
was a little odd like we're gonna tease
you with it and then we're gonna show
you the full thing in three minutes time
that's right yeah i don't quite get the
whatever it doesn't matter well once
they finally showed the whole thing it
looked pretty cool i like the idea that
we're gonna be piloting like zeppelins
and apparently an armored train or like
the behemoth vehicles sounds very cool i
wonder if they'll do anything like uh
2142's titan mode where you had like a
big
you know ship that you had to like take
down i wonder if that would be part of
the multiplayer perhaps uh this trade
looks alive and you guys seen lebanon in
that movie the
israeli tank movie where it all takes
place inside of a tank there's kind of a
lot of that happening there with like
all these dudes crowned in there so i
wonder if maybe that's part of the
single player yeah
it looks great though doesn't it well
the single players from different
people's perspective right so imagine
you'll get to play as the harlem hell
fighters the holland hell fighters the
british do we get to play germany
did at the start they were like we're
doing like a take on world war one yeah
yeah which is like obviously i think
it's just them being like we've got
world war one and i do think they've and
they've already said they've gone to a
lot of effort to research what was
actually used in combat and stuff like
that and incorporate heaps of that into
the game but i think it just means at
the end of the day we're playing a
battlefield game and it needs to be
about a full game so i think people were
quite worried is that like we're so
accustomed to all the the drones and the
the high tech that like it would be seen
as a step back and like be slow paced
and whatever but from this trailer at
least from the cut of this trailer yeah
definitely i think we can expect high
energy yeah look at this nonsense it's
ridiculous just high energy with horses
and
tanks
stabbing fools
and planes
and frigging windmills was that a
crossbow lots of destructibility they
also said there was going to be like
dynamic weather coming into it which
they kind of
had added into a bunch of the the
battlefield 4
maps especially the the ones and the
sort of ocean ones the island ones yeah
uh yeah looks interesting and that was
basically it that was that was ea's
press conference uh they are apparently
streaming now the battlefield
one multiplayer thing so we will not
hold you guys up any longer uh before i
let you guys go what was your favorite
thing you saw in ea's conference first
of all mr butterworth titanfall 2. okay
excited i reserve the right to change
that to andromeda when we see more fair
enough
yeah andromeda i just i yeah
they're gonna do it they're gonna do it
i have faith yeah we didn't i am the
optimist speaking of faith no sign of
mirror's edge at all actually no no no
it just came out though you know good
point at home playing every usually they
go like hey and we just released this
one please go buy it
or anything yeah after that we'll
probably be playing on the show floor or
something just to remind people yeah
yeah but it'll be like
the last of us that year uh okay so
that's the show uh for for now that is
one down
five to go make sure you hit that
subscribe button uh hit that follow on
youtube hit that follow button on twitch
if you're on there if you're watching on
gamespot stick around folks we will be
back at 6 30 bethesda's press conference
starts at seven we're already hearing
rumors of some crazy announcements
coming out of there uh not in fact not
stuff that leaked last week so you may
want to tune into that uh pretty late
for the europeans but it'll be worth it
i promise we will be live right here on
gamespot.com
e34 live or on twitch and on youtube
from 6 30 pacific that is four hours
from now do the math thank you so much
for watching and we will see you then
take care
you